hello and welcome to this video playing
Sita okay I've already had lost one game
against him and quite quite quite
drastically it seems okay yeah this is
some an interesting line I think the
blackest is fine here but it's some
interesting to play should be six over
oh god I have completely forgotten how
this is played
Jacobs is 95 for 3295 sediments maybe
a bit of a funny funny line yeah what
what white is doing here very strange
stuff maybe c6 was better than Bishop e6
quite a wiki wiki opening
yeah it's it's interesting he he wants
to go he wants to play some F form
maybe f4 f5 there's also c4 and for I
will cancel and I mean castles got FY go
f5 looks extremely stodgy but I probably
have to do it or Bishop f5 is said in
most F Bishop f5 it's interesting
actually cake cake
maybe I'm that's a bit more ambitious I
think f5 is okay but very again very
stodgy maybe then yeah anyway I try to
play this in a bit more why does that
work
and a bit more ambitious way that's what
I was trying to say
hmm odd it's actually possible that you
get some compensation even after this
blunder
and can I have five my position is a
little bit it's not so easy to play it's
got f5 and he's got a g5 in 95 maybe I
should have played Queen D 3 and then 95
and threatening Queen d3 though that
would help him invade yeah that I'm
going to play go for invasion and make
it a little bit more difficult for him
to coordinate his pieces
YUM oh do I do I get this going here
ig6
hmm
there's no way back
so let's do something pragmatic that's
not best I'm perfectly aware of it I
wanted something that is reasonably easy
to play
got to check here
mmm [ __ ] yeah he will also take some
points him yeah it still it's very
Jewish maybe King D to cover this oh
yeah or this one
yeah that splits the draw with the
opposite colored bishops I guess
very difficult to imagine how to get
anything here for both sides of course
yeah ma'am I should win after he gives
away the exchange but I the way it was
played that was not easy at all I mean
I'm not sure if I should win actually to
be honest because it was difficult to
play okay I went Bishop f5 which was
more ambitious than pawn to f5 and he
simply ya know blundered the exchange
takes young group e85 and now I invaded
but after a 5 I mean maybe this is not
good yeah 650 normal-looking moves so
this one yeah but now I didn't really
see what you do here because yeah he's
threatening to yeah not sure to trap my
queen yeah I saw I went here and I can
take f5 for the first set for City why
did I take a five ok not-not-not well
played and here yeah I think he did not
see that beforehand but I cannot cannot
win it just so it's just not possible
even after that I will use all those
pawns to say too much it's just a
drawing
just to draw yeah I should take a 5 that
was silly I didn't didn't see that at
all like here I was I was panicking a
little bit I should take the pawn and
that is probably not a position where
White has much compensation if
anything I get 96 and he has weakened
his King side quite a bit so that is
very good I should do that definitely
and in the opening I'd like to check
something Queenie f6 is correct there
should be six is also correct and I
cannot do anything else any of this this
92 I played queen g6 yeah I think he can
go shake he can take here yeah yeah I
saw that trick this is why I went Queen
to g6 which is probably not the best
move the engine just wants to cancel on
him I did not want this but yeah why not
I mean White's development is quite
quite sluggish I can probably do that
[Music]
one thing I wondered if he has g4 here
I'm on I'm running again I won that so
he can take it
okay yeah okay guys thanks for watching